in a previous video some of you were a
bit concerned about javascript's
performance because of its single
threaded nature so i thought hey let's
poke at that a bit jumping right to the
point does javascript have threads
sorta yeah i mean javascript itself is
single threaded but what they have is
the web workers api which allows you to
run scripts in the background off the
main execution thread in an entirely
different context there's a bunch of
different types of workers and details
here but we're going to focus
exclusively on the dedicated ones since
they're simple to understand before we
dive in we'll go over some quick example
code to get up to speed
so to create a worker it's as easy as
creating a new worker with the name of
the script that has the entry point or
the worker script
i'll have a second script here as the
worker and the code that runs in here
will actually be running in another
thread off the main thread
and we need to define an message handler
in here and for now we'll just have it
log the messages sent and then post back
its own
now in the main script i'll declare an
onmessage for the worker object which
will just again log some crap in the
console
then we can post a message to the worker
using the post message function and we
should be good to go
running this all you can see the log
statements show up in sequence in the
console
and that's the gist of it
so let's speed something up using
workers
i've gone ahead and made this dinky
little testing harness just to make
things a bit easier for us
it'll just take a test run it a bunch of
times recording times using
performance.now
after all that it'll spew the results
into the console both individual runs as
well as the total accumulated time
there's a threaded version too and that
basically does the same thing more or
less specifically we create an array of
workers to start
then we have a loop here which sets the
on message and this is where we can look
to see if this is the final bit of work
to be done
if it is great
record the time since we started and
throw that into the console
finally this last loop actually loops
over the work items doling them out to
the workers
in the previous video we covered
comparing c plus and javascript so let's
just go ahead and grab the first test we
did there the sum of squares
recall that this test really just
generates a bunch of crap data in an
array then loops over it doing some
pretty much pointless math squaring the
values and summing it all up to start
the first thing that runs is the single
threaded version and we'll do the test a
bunch of times in this case i just did
the test eight times
and that'll just kind of be the base
line to compare to
afterwards we can go ahead and run the
threaded version and i'll do that on two
threads to start
your first thought might be with two
threads we'll go twice as fast but the
first thing you notice is this actually
ran slower than the single threaded
version so what gives here
shouldn't have this been faster
we can try screwing around with the
settings a bit more see if that helps so
if i bump this up to four threads we see
some improvements i can keep jacking
this value up six threads or eight
threads
but we're kind of seeing a pattern
emerge here the improvements all kind of
suck
i mean they suck less and less as you
throw more cores at the problem but
these were all outperformed by just
doing it all on the main thread let's
use the performance tab to analyze this
a bit more closely so i've used the
reload and record functionality and i
grabbed a couple seconds of profiling
data now we can look at the main thread
here you can see all the individual
calls to test some squares here they all
just gonna happen one after the other
nothing really special to note other
than often it seems to show the first
few and then mashes the rest together
but you can make out that the timings
are roughly 30 milliseconds per
iteration over here this is the threaded
test and from here we can scroll down
and find the worker threads
notice how each of these worker on
message calls we can bring up the code
quickly but there's almost nothing in
here we receive the data from the main
thread run the benchmark and then post
it back and from the profile these on
message calls take considerably longer
than the main thread benchmark runs
we're losing a ton of time here
notice how the test time only takes
about 30 milliseconds or so on the
worker
but the whole on message called seems to
take a lot of time
and it's in the receiving and then
sending the data that we seem to be
losing an enormous amount of time
remember that each of these workers they
don't run in the same execution context
that the main thread does
in fact the mdn docs for web workers
specifically state that data passed
between the main page and workers is
copied not shared
and that happens using the structured
clone algorithm we're not really digging
into how it works but intuitively
copying data is never free
although the closer and closer you get
to a pure mem copy or just passing a
pointer the faster the copying is
just watch the video on cpu caches if
that doesn't make sense to you
so you can intuitively believe that the
more complex the data the slower the
structured clone algorithm will be and
thus the slower post message will go and
luckily i didn't have to actually
confirm that myself i found this website
from serma a web advocate at google and
they looked into the cost of post
message so i don't have to i can just
point at their work and what they found
was the larger and more complex the
objects you're copying the slower things
go to the surprise of absolutely nobody
but it's good to confirm it and to just
hammer the point home because i have
nothing better to do we reduce this test
to one thread and surprise surprise the
performance of the threaded version
absolutely blew
because we're doing just about
everything wrong
the takeaway here is that to go faster
in a threaded environment requires a bit
more finesse and planning than just
throwing crap at another core and
thinking it'll all work out so let's
examine a more realistic situation we'll
make things go faster
for a while i've been doing a series on
building procedural terrain and we do a
lot of the mesh building in separate
threads the nice thing about this test
is that you're mostly just sending a few
simple parameters there that takes
almost zero time to serialize
and all the work is procedurally
generated
so we can run this the first time using
two threads and what you see right out
of the gates is a gain for the threaded
version
it's quite a bit faster not twice as
fast considerably faster so we'll take
the win
let's take a closer look using the
performance tab again
so what i've done is recorded a profile
and we can poke around a bit in here
look at these on message calls what you
notice is that the tasks seemingly start
right away which kind of jives with our
expectation since the deserialization
cost now should be really small since
we're sending so little data to the
worker but the worker generates the mesh
data and has to send it back and that's
still costing us quite a bit of time
we can trivially confirm that it's
serialization time by sending back a
dummy dict v8 isn't smart enough to
optimize that workout so this will force
us to actually build the mesh but then
throw that work away and send back
nothing and what you'll notice from the
results is that we're getting a lot
closer to the performance being twice as
fast being on the workers so that tells
us that we need to kill that
serialization cost
the mdn docs show that the post message
function takes two parameters the
message which is transferred via the
structured cloning
and then this transfer argument which is
more interesting this lets us transfer
the ownership from one execution context
to another or in other words this is a
lot like moving a unique pointer in c
plus and the upside is that you don't
have to copy all that crap over so this
is potentially awesome the only small
caveat is that it has to be one of these
specific types that implements the
transferable interface like arraybuffer
in the code here instead of passing the
results directly to the message
parameter we're going to pack everything
into a couple of array buffers
so this block of code just allocates
them in some float32 views packs
everything together and then posts it
and sets the transfer arguments
now we run this and yay it's actually
really close to the same speed as
passing absolutely nothing back so this
is a big win
quick little a side note you can also
pass shared array buffers back and forth
between workers in the main thread and
even read and write simultaneously from
the same buffer from multiple threads
just remember that you need to use
atomic operations to mitigate against
concurrency issues we can talk about
that in another video anyway that aside
now that we have a lot of the speed
let's start jacking up the threads so
with three threads we see a good
improvement over the two thread case
and another good jump at four threads
at five threads though we didn't see
much if any gain which is a little
strange i pushed this up to six threads
and again nothing
at seven threads we're still seeing
pretty much the same timings that we saw
with four threads
but when i bumped this up to eight
threads we suddenly jumped this is
really interesting we kind of have a
performance cliff here throwing more
threads made zero difference until we
hit eight
using the performance tab we can take a
quick profile and that reveals the
culprit right away so from this you can
see that this worker here is getting two
sets of work and everyone else has to
kind of just sit around twiddling the
thumb since the amount of work wasn't
divisible by the number of workers which
makes sense if we just jack up the
number of work items and play with
things so let's just go with 64. it
doesn't really matter and on the first
run we see around 20 seconds or so give
or take on the single threaded version
versus 12 12 and a half seconds for the
two thread version fantastic improvement
almost twice as fast
at four threads we're still seeing good
results around seven to eight seconds or
so pretty great at six threads though
we're starting to see a serious drop off
in results getting somewhere in the six
and a half to seven second range which
is a really modest gain at this point at
8 threads that only just barely nudges
us further ahead on top of that
i'm seeing low to mid 6 seconds
depending on the run i tried running
this at 10 threads and this ended up
being slightly slower than the aid
thread scenario and at 12 threads well
this is pretty clear that not only is
this not getting faster it's actually
getting slower so what gives
i don't have unlimited cores of my cpu
and chances are you don't either
in fact i can look at my specific cpu i
have an i7 4790k
some of you said this is pretty decent
cpu but whatever it's a it's an old one
looking at the specs you can see that it
has four physical cores and with hyper
threading it has eight threads
and that correlates really well with our
results strong improvements up until the
four core mark and then really modest
gains after that
i mean we get gains but after that we
max out the hardware threads the problem
is after you've maxed out your threads
you're kind of tripping over your own
feet by throwing more threads at the
issue you need to be aware of what kind
of architecture you're running on
now javascript does have a way of
getting at that there's
window.navigator.hardware concurrency
which is the only way of grabbing the
number of threads you've got access to
also be aware that these are logical
cores not physical cores but after this
if you're doing cpu intensive stuff
you'll probably see similar fall offs if
you're doing i o then it's not a bigger
deal
so anyway that's a little exploration of
javascript's threading capabilities we
kind of touched on the surface a bit
played with some of the gotchas and
performance foot guns so hopefully you
don't run into the same
until next time cheers